south of france night in honor of
typhoon
some of the fans
have decided to wear berets they've put
a beret on his cutout there's a whole
section of fans wearing berets
they passed out baguettes
along with t-shirts you say kikuchi
lefty will go for seattle coming off his
shortest start of the season he went
just two and two thirds allowed seven
runs and his last start on the road trip
that'll bring up all-star catcher
salvador perez going strong after all
these years
banning 272 this year 34 home runs
and 82 runs banded in big strong
right-handed hitter the mariners have
the shift on for him the pitch on the
way swinging a ground ball off the foot
of you say he picks it up as the ball
rolls toward the plate he's got it
wheels throws the first in time to get
perez a kick save for you say kikuchi
and he's gonna
try to get a job with maybe with the
seattle kraken as a goalie so a great
save right there by you say kikuchi and
that's it for the royals here in the top
of the first no runs no hits and nobody
left on we go to the bottom of the first
our score
kansas city nothing and the mariners
coming up brad keller will pitch for the
royals tonight he's tied for the most
walks allowed in the league and his 5.43
earned average is the fourth highest
dangerous hitter at the plate hanniger
having a solid season 253 average 29
home runs and 73 driven in
here's the pitch ground ball to short
lopez gets into second for one on to
first not in time what a play by nikki
lopez diving to his left and just
keeping that from going to center field
now a dangerous hitter kyle zieger
here's the two row and that ball is
struck well into center field taylor
races back it's going to split the gap
and roll to the wall michael plays it
well
is
in time
michael a taylor doing it again with a
solid throw to the cutoff man
and the mariners have the bases loaded
with two down for jake fraley
a 3-0 pitch
lost him rbi friendly mariners lead
one-nothing third walk in the inning
frails picks up and rbi is 28th
now the batter is jared kellnick
and here it comes
inside corner strike three called and
brad got a break
with nikki lopez with some sparkling
defense the royals hold seattle to just
one run and they have to consider
themselves
very fortunate to only be down one
nothing at the end of the first inning
here's michael taylor banning 2 44.
here's the stretch and the 0-1 on the
taylor tries to bundle he's down to
beauty third base line charging
bare-handed the ball seeger the throw to
first then it's in time to get taylor
an outstanding play by kyle seeger
charging in he got to that ball about
halfway down the line toward home play
bare-handed it got on that back foot
fired a strike over the tie france in
time to get taylor that'll bring up
designated hitter hanzer alberto alberto
hitting 268 he was with baltimore last
year a home run with kansas city you say
a look back
at dozier here's the stretch and the
pitch on the way swinging a line shot of
the right field hannigar off to his left
he's there and makes the catch toward
the corner
alberto lights out to mitch haniger and
that will end the inning we head to the
bottom of the second now the number
eight batter cal raleigh here is the
one-two pitch and it swung on and missed
and that may have been his change-up now
we head back to the top of the order and
jp crawford
walked his first time up in a race down
a fielder's choice
here is the 1-2 pitch and it is in there
strike three goal
here comes emmanuel rivera
nine hitting third baseman
the 2-0
swinging a ground ball towards the shift
backhand sliding backhand toro second
baseman from shadow left throw on the
first dugout by france for round number
two
toro getting it done on both sides of
the bag at second top of the order with
merrifield kikuchi winds and fires
swinging it slice to right field hannah
sizes it up bites the lights leaps and
he makes the catch a little bunny hop
as he lost that one of the bank of
lights
over the bag at third base and the right
fielder haniger makes the catch
to retire the sign in order to the
bottom of the third one nothing mariners
they shade this left-handed hitter
seeger around to the right on the
infield nobody on one out o2 pitch
is the fastball that's popped up down
the left field third base line and what
a nice grab
off-balance catch by rivera going down
the left field line he got there before
ben and tindy did
and here's hunter dozier he has the
royals only base hit tonight the one-two
swing and a miss strike three a
strikeout for you say kikuchi is first
of the ball game abraham toro came over
that houston deal and there's a slider
that's lifted pretty deep to center back
goes taylor reaching up and he makes a
great catch and then runs into the wall
just to the left to straight away center
field great running catch by michael a
taylor
another sparkling play by the royals
defense tonight
now they're two down bases are loaded
for their left-handed hitting shortstop
jp crawford two and two on the batter
crawford
here's the pitch
slider is lifted to shallow center and
back to make a great catch nikki lopez
with a fourth great play the royals
defense has turned in through four
innings
the nintendo in his first year with
kansas city after five in boston
strike three called second k back to
back in fact
for kikuchi so one out for the royals
and here is center fielder michael
taylor
strike three call
three consecutive strikeouts by kikuchi
here is third baseman kyle seeger has
scored that one run in the first inning
here's the wind-up and the one will
pitch the seeger swinging to drive deep
to right center field o'harn going back
looking up and goodbye baseball kyle
seeger with his 30th home run of the
year matches his career high
and that 30th home front of the year
gives the mariners a two-nothing lead
here in the bottom of the fifth inning
holy smokes what a shot by seeger brad's
only gonna go four in a third and give
up two runs and he's coming out of the
game because
obviously his bicep or tricep is causing
him some
discomfort and the better will be left
fielder jake braley now the 1-1 pitch
swinging a well-hit ball deep to right
field back she goes and this one is gone
goodbye baseball jake fraley with his
ninth home run of the season it comes
with toro aboard a couple home runs for
the mariners here in the bottom of the
fifth and it's now the mariners four and
kansas city nothing what a shot by brady
that'll bring wood merrifield to the
plate well
he had a grand slam yesterday i think
he'd settle for a three-run homer here
1-0 on whitmer field chokes up on the
bat as he normally does waits for the
pitch in the lefty here it comes
and a fastball is pulled down the left
field line that's a fair ball into the
corner here comes o'hern around third he
scores rivera will stop at third it's an
rbi double for whitmer field the royals
are on the board it's four to one the
bases are loaded nobody out
and the royals best hitter this year
salvador perez will come to the plate
and the 2-0 and salvi
hits it well deep left center and that
ball is gone
a salvador perez grand slam
and the royals take the lead 5-4
back-to-back games with grand slams
yesterday with merrifield tonight
salvador perez he knew it instantly
and the batter will be one of their best
hitters kyle seeger
three infielders on the right side for
seeger open stance left-handed hitter in
the pitch swing and grab it to the right
side got by
the first baseman dozier whit picks it
up throws it back to dozier for the
three four three put out two or down
that'll bring up nikki lopez swanson
checks on rivera now the pitch and a
fast ball is like into center for a base
hit here comes rivera around third he
will score and the royals lead his two
it's six to four on a base it up the
middle an rbi base hit up the middle by
nikki lopez jarrett kelnick will lead
things off against irvin santana who had
a one two three bottom of the seventh
inning now the one one and it is swung
on hit pretty well left center field
racing back ben and tendy he leaps up
and makes a terrific catch
he took a home run away from jared
kellnick and kelnick holding his helmet
in disbelief
there is salvador perez one for four and
it was a big one
and now the pitch on the way to perez
swinging a ground ball to short jp's got
it from a knee the throw to first base
and it's in time to france to get perez
and that's going to retire the side and
the royals leave the bases loaded here
in the top of the ninth inning what a
job by johann ramirez to get out of that
jam
seeger has doubled and homered tonight
here's the 2-2 he taps one toward short
cut off
rivera his throw in time and the royals
win six to four